größe und herzlich willkommen namens
mike shiva und ja gewiss das jetzt fans
worker denn ich bin hellseher und
hellsehen das tut er am liebsten in
einem fernsehstudio in thun täglich
beantworten schieber und sein team hier
telefonische zukunftsfragen aller art
[Musik]
schönen guten morgen ich
sage es in aller öffentlichkeit ja mit
ausschuss frank beineke bezirks und das
würden wir auch gerne wissen aber
darüber später sie und guten morgen
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wie
auch mike und tasten mit ihm im studio
sind immer zwei seiner rund 50
mitarbeitenden quasi im hintergrund
jeder anruf kostet 4 franken 50 pro
minute daran verdienen auch diverse
private fernsehstation viva sich
sendezeit gekauft hat rufen sie an haben
die mut am anfang von der sendung
gelingt shiva selbst ist vorübergehend
eine stunde pro tag auf einer gratis
nummer erreichbar als dank dafür dass
2009 so erfolgreich gewesen sei da die
werbesendung mit mike shiva und seinem
kleinen imperium lässt die telefone und
damit auch die kasse klingelt die
genauen zahlen bleiben allerdings ein
geheimnis aber was genau ist ja denn
eigentlich ich weiß es nicht ich denke
wahrsager bis wo eigentlich am besten
tönt will wahrheit des stars ohne
eigentlich kein machen und das ist das
motto mehr bekommen im fernsehen hat sie
einfach das schwarze loch vor der kamera
vor sich wie funktioniert das dass sie
tatsächlich kontakt an seiner person
arbeitet es ist so dass jeder mensch er
stimme oder deine stimme hätte schwingen
jeder name jedes geburtsdatum head sind
die bedeutung denn die form vor ort auch
wenn man das alles liegt seit dort und
neue lehrstühle vor der wahrnehmung vom
hellsichtige und demokraten geht's mit
möglichkeit als schnelldenker
maschinenraum vorteile und ausgeübte
frage konkrete antwort
der hellseher zeichnet sich also durch
menschenkenntnis und gutes zu hören aus
aber fangen wir vorne an und versuchen
von seiner mutter zu erfahren wie mike
der sich übrigens den nachnamen schieber
erst als erwachsener zugelegt hat wie
sie seine talente entdeckt
das am 16
der vater starb aber früh und eine lehre
war kein thema mehr die beziehung
zwischen mutter und sohn wurde noch
engel und die mutter prägte sein klar
das team
aus nur mutter und sohn vertraut man
alles ist
was menschen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
gegangen hier richtig sehen
das weiß ja
dass ich
das erklären dass sie schon bewusst dass
mein held sondern als kind haben wir
einfach gewisse sachen gemacht oder zeit
oder das irgendwie entwickelt ob deshalb
nicht als 1000 kunden
genau
[Musik]
das nur interessant
es gar nicht klar dass immer das so wenn
leertaste und trocknen has today show
mit gabler und messe ganzes haus niemals
beantwortet
dass ich glaube wenn wir das in die
wiege gelegt berühmt weil es mir nicht
wenn das nicht irgendwann fahren sondern
es ist maxi und die sächsische so normal
dass man gar nicht mehr so bissig aber
sei es mehr auge
beide sind überzeugt mike hat seine
hellseherischen fähigkeiten vom
großvater mütterlicherseits geerbt die
er war zirkusartist kleider finden sie
von ihm keine fotos mehr schon in jungen
jahren tingelte mit einer hypnose show
durch die schweiz
[Musik]
harpstedt
schnell vergangen das steht fest
eschenbach alles ist entspannt
und lacht und lacht
so verdiente schäfer sein erstes geld
und war froh der schule in thronen zu
sein
doch doch
na ja überhaupt
nicht macht ist
die gefahr
[Gelächter]
rechnen ist gutes geschäft und das
geschäft mit der zukunft floriert ganz
offensichtlich
und
büroarbeit mager nicht sagt schäfer
dafür sei patrick gut dazu ständig der
hand leser ist seit 20 jahren chivas
geschäftspartner
wer ist eigentlich der cheftrainer beide
wenn sie bei der schiffe
der woche
im hintergrund ist das letzte worte ja
also es ist so eigentlich sagt die sehr
wenig und wie auch da wo am wenigsten
macht das überhaupt da sich der pater
geschenk der geschichte patrick ebert tv
aber ich bin da wo am schluss war es ne
pas zeitnahes und nicht die fragen dann
ist es ja so wenig säcke
patrick arbeitet und mike präsentiert
könnte man also sagen inzwischen hat das
unternehmen der beiden über 50 leute auf
der lohnliste
der inhaberin und der politische
geschäftsführer also muss etwas
beantwortete
ja wenn man dass es so natürlich sei der
werft glühten ist das betrug die zahl
und das durch männliche libido ich aber
es ist ja nicht so dass wir es geschafft
haben wir jetzt da wirklich 50.000 sind
sondern es ist eigentlich so dass die
alle selbständig sind die sind der
heimat sie sind natürlich wenn man es
genau nimmt sind bis festgestellt in den
rat einzieht ausstellung so attraktiv
wirkt das auch im studio auftreten
es gibt keine teamsitzungen und vieles
passiert spontan
heute wünscht dass seine angestellten
video porträts bis internet aufnehmen
dafür biss wünsche dass man das recht
70er verarbeiter sinne des volkes
wir machen das nicht
nur mit und ohne karte schon
auffallend hell sehnt und anhören
[Gelächter]
mein name ist elisa mein penis als zwei
jahre nicht zu vergessen viva tv ist
eine reine werbesendung für lebens
beratungen aller gattung ein auftritt am
bildschirm ist deshalb das große ziel
für die telefon beraterinnen das ist top
chef vor allem darin dass ich meinen
beruf
denn dass ich einfach drauf dass ich auf
dem teppich sehen wir entwickeln der
chef muss sich notgedrungen doch
zwischendurch mit programm beschäftigen
und so fehlt ihm zwangsläufig die zeit
alles was in seiner verantwortung über
die fernsehsender geht selbst
anzuschauen
mehr ganz tolle runde ganz toll ganz
tolle zuschauer die informieren und dann
hat er ungefähr zehn bis zwanzig
stammkunde auf spione sind froh über den
spezial leute und die beraterin sache
verwickelt wo man noch keine
informationen bekommen und dann bekommen
sie im prinzip sind test aber eigentlich
muss man sagen es gibt natürlich immer
schwarze schaf und mehrheit vor allem
halt auch bei der esoteriker sehr
schlechte fahrer gemacht obwohl die
hellseher ich bin nicht bereit
halte die sache ruhiger vertreter
der druck von
doktor später ich immer mehr ein doch
schon
hellseher wie sie sein liegt der
kreuzung zukunft wie sie der
liebeskunst der wiese ausgesät aber es
gibt so spezialisten die werden zwar vom
hellseher zum therapeuten der urfassung
patient
er hat ein paar monate für schäfer tv
gearbeitet und wurde rausgeschmissen
aber nicht etwa weil er falsch beraten
hätte sondern weil er quasi zu
konkurrenz wurde
entweder hätte man sagt da es für lloyds
führer oder aber man muss kann das
bedürfnis entwickelt saubere sondern
allein auf zwei linien hotline hätten
kräftig kostet von einer 450 in
mexiko-stadt und
patrick wind vorteil dass sie der anruf
unserer hotline dann heiße megaposter
gestellt seine eigene hotline läuft aber
nicht jetzt arbeitet er für die
konkurrenz notabene auch geführt von
einer ehemaligen mitarbeiterin von shiva
tv und wieder zum gleichen preis wie
wahrnimmt pro telefonierte stunde 270
franken ein da würde uns doch
interessieren wieviel super verdient hat
sich gestaffelt sie also je nach den
vier minuten das man telefoniert hat ein
team ohne tor du hast jetzt tue sich
hinter gemacht oder 2000 minute und es
ist irgendwie gestaffelt sie das weiß
habe ich glaube bis zu 70 befundet
minute habe ich 20 franken pro stunde
gesprochen habe mit den rund 20 franken
und finde ich das okay
ich sage dass sie dem moment sehr okay
gefunden wo ich eine frage hks chance
ksk der öffentlichkeit nicht gesicht
zeigen mehr bekannt machen ich habe das
ganze wirklich mitgemacht
das werden wir für zukunft bis bringen
aber nein also mitarbeiter womöglich
bringt und leistet ist das sehr wenig
das mini putzfrau hat schaut einführung
effizient
[Musik]
selbst wenn maxi war immer wieder betont
dass fernsehen machen doch eine teure
sache sei und sämtliche einnahmen sofort
wieder in die studios und in die technik
investiert würden scheint sein geschäft
auf den einen oder anderen patzen
abzuwerfen
wenn man jeden tag im fernsehen
magazine kleider wie muss wechsel zum
beispiel meine schuhe natürlich überall
sie lege sie hat keine festen schuhe
ziemliches putzfimmel denn harley ganz
vorne und momentan ständig des hobbits
liebe
und so sachen spitze so
dass annika wenn sich mit glitzer das er
braucht natürlich als großes bett das
ist ganz klar will ich schlafen
damit mein
hund schläft auch im bett ein hund ist
hier blinkt und schlaf
der schlüssel sei wies das scharf wie
ein mönch und einem brandanschlag das
macht dass
das handwerk nicht wurde so wenige wie
du also das ist wirklich aber wenn etwa
gebremst wenig skeptisch heißt es gibt
es probleme es gelangen
da wäre dann gibt's das problem es gibt
es diese probleme beim prinz oder
prinzessin es wäre das problem
wie dem auch sei sein letzter fester
partner sei jedenfalls patrick guter
gewesen
das ist richtig mehr sind sie weg sie in
hand miteinander er bezieht kam es in
einer unter begegnet und es ist eine
verwandtschaft zwischen teil von erich
behrendt l wo ihm und mehr ein- zweimal
tägliche honig also wir sind intern sind
es barock sie einfach darauf aussage als
liebespaar aber energisch und mit einer
frau zusammen und enthüllte zwei herzige
kind da bin ich götti und ich bin
glücklich weil die frau ihm egal wie und
ganzen tolle frau wir sind immer noch
die beste freunde und wir sind immer
noch gut die beziehung miteinander
finden sofort im garten ist im großen
kohle gibt
[Musik]
das ist meine ersatzfamilie sich die
dauer zu mir und dem rauchen süchtig und
sagen aber ich finde es gut und
friedlich da aber ich muss erst ab und
zu hier haben eine vierzimmerwohnung
scheint und saladins für eine person
allein schon etwas groß inzwischen ist
es ist so dass ich mit abgefunden haben
dass ich bleibe und
eigentlich die negative eigentliches
total positiv und bedeutet glücklich
darüber zügig gruppe das ist gar nicht
so schlecht ist wenn man nicht neidig
zum egoismus hat wie nicht und auch gern
macht was man wort denn glaube dennis
befasst zum einzelgänger
geboren und somit bin ich solo und
glücklich
an konzerte beispielsweise können und
mit bodyguard sagt sie war alleine
unterwegs werde er nämlich oft
angepöbelt er polarisiert das weiß er
die rücklagen sind entweder esoteriker
und der ludwig nicht kenne
willi natürlicher bisserl anders
funktionieren will ich natürlich auch im
worden ende will die augen ein
gesteigertes com net oder das ist ein
blödsinn und will ich auch nicht eher so
ein
mega es afrika also das bin ich jetzt
wirklich absolut nicht
aber nochmal was genau bekommen seine
kunden denn eigentlich für ihr geld von
den sogenannten hellsehern erhält serie
freiheit der wünsche und oft bauer und
positive energie zu
bringen es führe wenn er sich wünscht
und zwar zum erfolg
erfolg halten ihrem fall einen partner
klar der ruf zum ersten mal an während
40 minuten probierte es mit der
gratisnummer der wahl wird sie von einer
tonband stimme animiert doch eine der
kostenpflichtigen beraterinnen
anzuwählen hallo michael ja klar ich
hätte kein christ was mich so wie ein
privatlabor erwartet speziell was
familie und partnerschaft abel und das
geburtsdatum
nach ein paar weiteren fragen china
während rund vier minuten in die zukunft
und sagt dass ein mann in ihr leben
treten werden
tut er aber karte zeigen die sind sehr
positiv
die sind sogar erfreulich positiv also
erstens einmal ist der euro auf dich
zukommt wo er wird es denke dass ich
eher kritisch oder auch frisch aus der
beziehung noch und und der leyen ja die
einzige karte und egoistisch ist
katastrophe horte und das heißt du hesch
irgendwie einfach
bezweckt das ist völlig falsch ist sie
kult
spitze beschrieben und hat gesagt dass
ich sehr speziell ist und wie habe ich
möchte speziell
auf der wache es ist schon zu treffen
sie also hätten götter und dämonen
seiner
frau schmitz leiter der können user
findet dass das ich hatte immer die frau
seien ohne große
not an
der frau wieder mit einem jahrgang
sicherlich wird ja schuld bisher lag das
ist schwierig das stimmt ja aber ich
danke so nach der usa hat schon so tönt
dass es immer wieder frei ist und das
ist ja richtig
tradition einmalige sache und für mich
stimmt das so aber schluss jetzt nur
dass zeitnot probiere ich glaube ich
lebe überraschen was auf mich zurück und
das rezept besteht also vor allem aus
lebenserfahrung gepaart mit der kunst
den anrufenden ein gutes gefühl zu geben
es geht nur sagen die sind allgemein es
gibt auch bin sehr wahrheit wo man
verbindet in einer aussage es ist nicht
100 prozent alles hellseher sondern da
ist ein großer prozentsatz aus um den
menschenverstand
hellseherische linear teil aber das
linear teil von hälse ist wichtig um
ganz bestimmt die punkt auf den punkt
bringen
und vom ganzen herzen und das ist alle
wichtigste öffnete auch iris herz und
mache sich um zertifizierte wo sie gab
danke ganz
verbieten was machen sie wenn ihnen mal
nur die falt eine präferenz ist einfach
nett was sagt das geht nicht ich habe
immer minikicker und die harmonie
wahrnehmung und ja immer mini antwort
aber es geht frage muss keine antwort
geht wie zum beispiel
wenn steht mini ururgroßmutter und da
geht bei mir grenzen und der moralischen
überlegungen dass man sei bisher einfach
nicht macht und vor allem neckar machte
dann zustande
wenn ein projekt grund und seitdem immer
fremd denn zeige
die tendenz dass der bvb gut da hund
oder was auch immer definierten personen
einfach als schuldige für office wo die
drei personen wie sie um kraft treten
willi findet das ist nicht richtig
das verlangt er auch von seinen
mitarbeitenden neue berater bewerben
sich in scharen und werden den
wöchentlichen castings getestet
bodenständige laute wolle er sagt der
chef ob daher in weiß eine chance hat ja
innerhalb der lebensberater sehen dass
natürlich ein ritterschlag
[Musik]
jetzt haben sie jetzt unter raum damit
sie heute wirklich angenommen wird oder
was werden sie tun ich stelle einfach
ich sein natürlich sein und ja einfach
denn einfach davon überzeugt dass ich
gut bin und das ist das team sicherlich
verstärken werden kann
wichtig für mich dass er positive
wortwahl hat dass er positive vorjährige
keine schwarz ärgern sondern ich will
die hellseher das heißt liegt wo einfach
immer nur schlecht gesehen und negativ
gesehen die vorderrad weg
hallo noch mal zusammen
sah bei dem die ähnlichkeit mit jener
rein zufällig sei wie er sagt muss
patrick maicon sekretärin am anders je
eine frage beantworten
ich bin alleine
und wird das so bleiben oder hast du
oder siehst du das etwas auf mich
zukommt
also eigentlich im grund vorweg möchten
die taten nicht wissen lassen möchten
garten die ich wissen lassen dass
eigentlich diese frage eigentlich nichts
anderes als dass du eine
selbstbestätigung haben möchtest ball
die ja eigentlich einer gewissen art und
weise die tendenz und die richtung schon
klar ist fast auf dich zugekommen
mannschaft also auf der hatz erfasst und
kann getrost davon ausgehen dass
hellseher mike seine zukunft sowieso
schon kennt nach rund zehn minuten ist
der fall für die jury klar
[Musik]
es wird einfach in
exotischen touch und ich glaube das
gefühl dass es
störungen
das
beständige
sieht freizeit aus verschieden und seine
entourage der wohnwagen ist ein geschenk
von mike an patrick diva hat früher
darin gelebt ist aber wegen seinem
geschäft vor ein paar jahren sesshaft
geworden in seinem herzen aber sei er
ein fahrender deshalb wohl er sich
wieder einen wohnwagen oder ein
wohnmobil anschaffen
natürlich etwas standesgemäßes
schließlich ist der unternehmer
relativ gut
wenn sich nicht alle mit zwei einzelnen
wenn sich einen großen bett also
dieses exemplar für rund 80000 franken
würde ihm schon gefallen
jetzt geht es wirklich nicht gerechnet
sie als nur sehr
schlecht ist es nicht und wenn wir für
unterwegs ist kennt das wenn man mal
aufgeklappte nick ein bild machte das
ist besonders bei mit bleibt denn ist
das einfach bis ins ziel thema immer
wieder werke und aus dem grund bin ich
halt schon sehr sehr interessiert wieder
ruhiger er weiß ja nie was kommt ja sie
ja schon oder ja ich schaute sehr gut
wider erwarten das wenn es denn kommt
dass sie werke und der vw
aber dann sicher nur mit chauffeur
[Musik]
und übrigens der kandidat in wales die
er gehört jetzt auch zum shiva team
[Musik]